Bonjour à tous !
Sauf à mes voisins du dessus et à ceux qui
font la pub de NordVPN. Cette vidéo est sponsorisée
par NordVPN, plus d'infos en fin d'épisode.
Faut que je vous dise un truc : pneumatophore.
Et aussi : non, la Terre n’est pas plate.
Mais je vais mettre tout le monde d’accord,
elle est pas ronde non plus. En réalité,
la Terre est une vieille patate. Et on le
sait grâce à la géodésie, la Cristina
Cordula des sciences de la Terre, celle qui
lui dit “mmmh nan mais t’as trop une morphologie
en Thêta, ma grande”.
Mais avant d’en arriver à cette patate
(la Terre, pas Cristina, j’oserais pas),
notre bout de caillou qui flotte dans l’espace
est passé par plein de formes différentes.
Dans la tête des gens.
La Terre a notamment été un disque. Le single
des Lacs du Connemara. Eh oui, noraj les globistes.
A l’Antiquité, vous auriez été la risée
de tout le monde.
Car chez nos antiques Grecs, la Terre était
une tortilla cernée par le guacamole du fleuve
Océan. Et le tout reposait sur diverses choses
selon les versions : de l’eau, de l’air
comme dans un jeu de air hockey, ou de la
piña colada. Ah non ça c'est ce qu'ils buvaient
pendant leurs recherches.
Et par-dessus, notre plat de résistance était
couvert d’une cloche, le ciel, avec les
étoiles qui défilent à la surface. Et une
fois arrivées en bout de course, comment
font-elles pour revenir à leur position de
départ chaque jour ? Ha, bonne question ! Eh,
ben, euh… A la nage, en empruntant le fleuve
Océan bien sûr ! Et non, une fois n’est
pas coutume, je ne ferai pas de blague sur
les migrants.
Quand soudain, arriva celui qui vint ruer
dans les brancards de la doxa. Le Didier Raoult
de l’époque, sauf que crédible et compétent.
J’ai nommé : Anaximandre de Mulet. Milet,
pardon. Nous sommes au 6e siècle avant Jésus-Christ,
juste avant l’invention des minitels, quand
ce bon Anax nous sort entre la poire et le
fromage : Vous voyez l'univers ? Eh bah c'est
un grand tourbillon. Et, en équilibre immobile
au centre de l'infini, dans l'œil du cyclone,
flotte notre bonne vieille Terre. Comme ça,
elle lévite dans le rien.
Et elle ressemble à un cylindre comme une
colonne grecque coupée, trois fois plus large
que haute. Nous, on baguenaude au sommet,
sur la section plane.
Ça a pas l'air dit comme ça, un tronçon
de salami qui lévite, mais c'est une idée
révolutionnaire ! Ça a dû être un peu
flippant pour les gens à l’époque de se
dire qu'ils flottaient en équilibre au-dessus
du vide. Et en-dessous du vide. Et sur les
côtés. Mais oui, je pèse mes mots, c'est
une révolution pour l'époque. Peut-être
même la toute première révolution cosmologique.
À tel point que le philosophe du XXe siècle
Karl Popper a… (sonnerie à la porte, je
sors du cadre)
(La porte s'ouvre, plan sur les 2 zététiciens
de jeovah)
Bonjour, vous avez dit Karl Popp…
(La porte leur est claquée au nez, elles
se regardent)
Désolée, j'ai invoqué les zététiciens,
erreur d'inattention… donc je disais, ce
brave Karlo a appelé cette idée « l'une
des idées les plus audacieuses, les plus
révolutionnaires, les plus prodigieuses de
toute l'histoire de la pensée humaine ».[a]
C'est ce que je me dis tous les matins quand
je décide de me lever. Bon ok, tous les midis.
Plan zets "on n'a même pas eu le temps de
lui parler de son compte formation CPF"
Donc c'est une idée brillante tout ça mais
en plus ça permet de résoudre cette histoire
de la course des astres qui se répète. Suffit
que les étoiles passent sous la Terre pour
regagner la ligne d’arrivée ! Et de départ,
du coup.
C’est déjà un progrès, mais c’est pas
fini. Parce que quelque temps plus tard, un
autre boug se ramène : Parménide. Lui se
dit “hmmm nan mais voyez, puisque le Ciel
est sphérique et qu’on vit dans un monde
parfait, et c’est pas Ilona qui me contredira
là-dessus, eh ben de facto la Terre l’est
aussi. Sphérique. CQFD. Ce que ferait Donald.”
Bon. Une nouvelle hypothèse. C’est bien
mignon, mais va falloir prouver tout ça maintenant.
Fastoche, nous dit Aristote qui nous montre
sa lune. La Lune. ‘Rgardez ça là, pendant
les éclipses, l’ombre de la Terre sur notre
satellite préféré est toujours ronde ! Ergo,
de facto, mutatis mutandis, lorem ipsum, la
Terre est une grosse boule.
Bon y’a pas que ça. Autre preuve, toujours
en regardant le ciel : quand on change de
latitude, si vous marchez un peu du Nord vers
le Sud ou l’inverse (mais franchement qui
aurait envie de faire l’inverse je vous
le demande), eh bah vous verrez pas les mêmes
étoiles dans le ciel. Ça c’est possible
parce qu’on marche sur une boule. Enfin
techniquement une patate, mais ne brûlons
pas les étapes.
Bon, à partir de là, on sait que la Terre
est ronde. Sauf ces platistes d’Épicuriens
qui font la sourde oreille et qui continuent
à croire à ces histoires de planète tortilla,
mais c’est eux qui tournaient pas rond (rires).
Si la Terre est ronde, c’est cool, on peut
en déterminer le rayon ! C’est là qu’arrive
Érathostène à cheval sur son chameau. Mais
pas le temps de niaiser, ici on cause de la
forme de la Terre pas de sa taille, pour ça
je vous renvoie vers l’excellente vidéo
de J’m’énerve pas j’explique.
Donc, la Terre est ronde. Bien. Bien bien
bien bien bien. On le sait depuis l’Antiquité.
Bien bien bien. Au Moyen-Âge, on le savait
aussi. Personne n’affirmait que la Terre
était plate, ça c’est une fake niou mais
je vous laisse voir cette vidéo-là que j’ai
faite chez Info ou Mytho? si ça vous intéresse.
Et aussi la géniale vidéo de L’Histoire
nous le dira ou celles non moins géniales
de Defakator.
Bon là, il se passe plus grand chose pendant
un moment.
Mais la fête reprend à la fin du 17e siècle.
Par une série d’avancées théoriques confirmées
par des observations, on va se rendre compte
que la planète n’est pas une sphère parfaite.
C’est plus un machin aplati, un ellipsoïde
de révolution aplati, pour les intimes.
Mais le débat, celui qui enflammera les scientifiques
de l’époque encore plus que faut-il mettre
ou pas de la crème fraîche dans les pâtes
carbo, c’est de savoir si la Terre est aplatie
plutôt comme ça ou plutôt comme ça (déformation
au montage).
C’est pas de la rigolade. Les Français
et les Anglais se sont affrontés à grand
coups de “sources?”. Pour les Anglais,
menés par Newton, la Terre est aplatie aux
pôles. Il fait son malin avec sa nouvelle
théorie de la gravitation universelle là.
Les Français, c’est l’ancienne école
de Descartes qui pense que la Terre est allongée
aux pôles et aplatie à l’équateur, un
peu comme un suppositoire.
Reste à mener des expériences pour savoir
qui a raison. Par chauvinisme, j’aurais
été complètement team Descartes.
Ah ben oui nous aussi. Descartes, c’est
celui qui a dit : “Le doute…”
Voilà comment les génies de l’époque
ont tiré cette affaire au clair. Difficile
de connaître la forme de ce sur quoi on est
assis quand on n’a pas le recul nécessaire.
Aujourd’hui, suffirait d’envoyer un texto
au conducteur de la Tesla en orbite, mais
à l’époque, c’était pas la même. Alors
ils se sont basés sur les méridiens, ces
lignes imaginaires qui relient les deux pôles
géographiques. Vous saurez que le terme générique
pour ces lignes, méridiens comme parallèles,
c’est graticule. Voilà c'est cadeau. Faites-en
bon usage.
Donc, nos méridiens. Prenons un méridien
et profitons-en pour couper la Terre en deux
en suivant cette ligne imaginaire avec notre
couteau. On peut diviser cette section en
360 parties d’angle identique, qu’on va
appeler un degré. Ben oui on fait ce qu’on
veut, c’est imaginaire tout ça. Ce morceau-là,
c'est un arc de méridien. Si la Terre était
parfaitement sphérique, chaque longueur d’arc
serait égale. Mais si la planète est légèrement
aplatie à l’équateur, comme le pensent
les mangeurs de grenouilles, l'arc près des
pôles sera plus court que celui près de
l’équateur. Et si, au contraire, elle est
aplatie aux pôles comme l’affirment les
rosbifs, ce sera l’inverse.
Bon. Y’a plus qu’à envoyer des stagiaires
nous mesurer tout ça.
Cassini père et fils ont alors tracé une
ligne droite du nord au sud en France… qui
passe par Dunkerque, Paris et Collioure. Reste
plus qu’à mesurer la distance entre ces
trois villes !
Plus facile à dire qu’à faire puisque
c’était bien avant Google maps, et les
cartes de l’époque étaient pas ultra fiables.
Pas question de dérouler un mètre enrouleur
d’un bout à l’autre de la France non
plus, alors pour s’en sortir, les savants
de l’époque ont utilisé une vieille technique
de triangulation : on avance en enchaînant
les triangles en prenant des points de repère
visibles de loin comme des clochers d’églises.
Et grâce aux joies de la trigonométrie,
on arrive à en déduire à peu près la distance
entre le point de départ et le point d’arrivée.
On compare ensuite la longueur de l’arc
pour un degré de méridien, entre d’une
part Paris-Dunkerque, et d’autre part Paris-Collioure.[b]
Les Cassini obtiennent une distance plus petite
au nord qu’au sud (à l’image : 56 960
toises au Nord (111,072 km) contre 57 097
au Sud (111,340 km)). Conclusion des Français
: la Terre serait donc bien allongée vers
les pôles. Suppositoire 1-ballon de rugby
0.
Entre parenthèses, je trouve ça incroyable
de se dire que ce genre de recherches cruciales
a eu lieu dans notre pays, là où peut-être
vous-mêmes vous résidez. Sauf si vous êtes
David Hallyday, Florent Pagny, Sébastien
Loeb ou Arthur.
Mais faut croire que les Anglais étaient
moins emballés que moi. Alors, l’Académie
royale française s’est dit qu’elle allait
refaire l’expérience en prenant des points
beaaaucoup plus distants sur le globe. On
compare toujours deux degrés de méridien,
l’un en Laponie, à haute latitude, l’autre
au Pérou, à basse latitude. Louis XV envoie
donc une expédition tout là-haut mesurer
la longueur de l’arc du méridien du Père
Noël,[c] et une autre au niveau de l'équateur
pour déguster des ceviche d’alpagas.
Je vous la fais courte, les expéditions à
l’époque c’était pas une sinécure.
L’une aura duré un an, l’autre 8, avec
des péripéties dignes d’Homère (l’antique,
pas le Simpson ; quoique…). Y’en a même
un qui a été tué par la chute d’une poutre.[d]
Et c’est qu’un élément parmi tant d’autres.
Bref, l’arc de Laponie, situé à une latitude
de 66°N, est plus long que celui du Pérou
sur l’équateur ! (57 438 toises vs 56 753
toises)[e] Donc l’inverse de ce qu’on
avait trouvé en France. Voilà qui assoit
une bonne fois pour toutes la victoire des
rosbifs de newtoniens. Pauvre, pauvre Descartes.
Guy Descartes c’est le meilleur !
Aplatissement actuel et pourquoi
Donc Newton avait raison. Par ses savants
calculs, il avait prédit que les manchots
en Antarctique et les baleines en Arctique
étaient 27 km plus proches du centre de la
Terre que les pumas à l’équateur. Dans
les faits, aujourd’hui on est plutôt sur
21 km mais eh, en 300 ans ça a pas beaucoup
bougé !
Mais alors, pourquoi qu’elle est aplatie
aux pôles, me demandâtes-vous ? Eh bien
parce qu’elle tourne, mon bon Galilée ! Je
vais vous apprendre un truc incroyable : la
Terre fait un tour complet sur elle-même
en 24h. En vrai c’est plutôt 23 h 56 min
4,1 s, mais on s’en fout. Allez donc me
faire un petit tour dans un manège. Plus
il tournera vite, et plus vous allez avoir
l’impression d’être expulsé vers l'extérieur.
Cette force qui vous boute hors de votre destrier
en bois tel Jeanne d'Arc les Anglais, c’est
ce qu’on appelle la force centrifuge. Décrite
par un petit copain de Newton, Huygens, et
qui l’a d’ailleurs bien inspiré pour
cette histoire de Terre aplatie.
Cette force-là est bien plus forte à l’équateur
qu’aux pôles. Ben oui, imaginez si vous
vous tenez pile poil sur le pôle Nord, vous
n’aurez pas à bouger d’un poil pour rester
au même endroit pendant que la Terre tourne.
Si en revanche si vous voulez courir sur place
sur le graticule de l’équateur, vous devrez
courir à 1675 km/h ! Ca c’est du tapis
de course.
Comme l’équateur est plus loin de l’axe
de rotation de la Terre que les pôles (qui
eux, sont littéralement dessus), la force
centrifuge est la plus forte à l’équateur
et nulle aux pôles. Elle va étirer la planète
aux basses latitudes et la tasser aux plus
hautes latitudes.
Ce qui est rigolo, c'est que cette force centrifuge
s’exerce dans le sens opposé à la gravité.
Du coup, l'une va atténuer l'autre et la
pesanteur sera moins forte à l'équateur
qu'aux pôles. Mais pas beaucoup moins forte
: de 0.3% seulement.
Ce qui contribue le plus à cette différence
de pesanteur, c'est le rayon de la Terre !
Plus vous êtes loin du centre de la Terre,
donc plus vous descendez vers l’équateur,
moins vous subirez l’attraction gravitationnelle
de la Terre. Et en plus comme vous vous éloignez
de l’axe de rotation, la force centrifuge
augmente, ce qui réduit encore un petit peu
le poids. Je parle bien du poids et pas de
la masse. Moralité, si vous voulez perdre
du poids rapidement et sans effort, suffit
d’aller près de l’équateur !
Et c’est aussi pour ça qu’on lance les
fusées dans ces régions de basse latitude
: la pesanteur y est moins forte et on profite
de la force centrifuge pour donner de l’élan
à nos bolides.
Eh oui, donc, la gravité varie à la surface
de la Terre. Les plus attentifs en cours de
physique auront peut-être retenu que sur
Terre, on considère que l'accélération
de la pesanteur vaut environ 9,81 m/s2. Sauf
qu’en fait non ! Pas tout à fait. C’est
en moyenne. En vrai, ça bouge entre 9,78
et 9,83 m/s². A cause d’abord, du rayon
terrestre qui varie, et dans une moindre mesure,
de la force centrifuge.
Mais revenons à nos scientifiques du XVIIe
siècle. S’ils ont pu se rendre compte que
la pesanteur variait à la surface de la Terre,
c’est grâce à… une pendule. Oui, une
pendule. Ils ont pris une pendule à balancier
parfaitement réglée à Paris et l’ont
emportée en Guyane. Pas sûre qu’elle soit
passée en bagage cabine. Surprise : là-bas,
la pendule accusait 2mn30 de retard chaque
jour comparé aux horloges de Paris !
Faut savoir que la période d’oscillation
d’un pendule dépend de la gravité terrestre,
parce que c’est la gravité qui ramène
le pendule vers le bas dès qu’il s’écarte
de la verticale. Plus la gravité est forte,
plus le pendule est ramené rapidement vers
la verticale et donc plus il oscillera rapidement
Bingo, la pesanteur n’est donc pas la même
à Paris et en Guyane ! Et c’est bel et
bien lié au rayon de la Terre.
C’est ce qu’on pourrait appeler une des
premières mesures gravimétriques, c’est-à-dire
pour déterminer la valeur de la gravité
en un certain point du globe. On s’est empressé
de lancer d’autres expéditions scientifiques
après ça, pendule à la main, pour récolter
plein de données gravimétriques sur Terre.
Et en bout de course, de dessiner cette splendide
patate.
Et c’est là que ça devient intéressant.
Oui parce qu’avant c’était juste l’intro.
Ca y est, on a mis les deux pieds dans le
domaine de la géodésie, cette science qui
s’intéresse à la figure de la Terre (c’est-à-dire
sa forme et ses dimensions). Elle peut même
être considérée comme la première forme
de géographie moderne !
Quand je vous dis qu’on vient d’y arriver,
c’est faux bien sûr. Les Cassini avec leurs
triangles, là, c’était déjà de la géodésie.
De la géodésie géométrique, qui est utilisée
par les géographes, pour faire des cartes,
notamment pour votre GPS. Ben oui, parce qu’il
faut connaître la forme exacte de la Terre
pour pouvoir la cartographier.
Mais il y a une autre facette de la géodésie
que j’aime particulièrement, (non pas que
la géographie ce soit pas intéressant mais
bon on parle de sciences ici quand même)
c’est la géodésie physique, et notamment
la gravimétrie. Celle qui vise entre autres
à déterminer la gravité et qui nous donne
cette fameuse patate sous LSD.
Pour fêter ça, j’ai acquis cette splendide
carte géologique qui montre comment la gravité
change selon l’endroit où on est sur Terre
!
On va regarder ensemble comment la lire. C’est
pas directement la gravité qui est représentée,
mais les anomalies gravimétriques. En gros,
on mesure la gravité à un endroit, on compare
à une valeur théorique (ce qu’on devrait
avoir si la Terre était un joli ellipsoïde
de révolution tout régulier). Si on a un
champ de pesanteur supérieur à ce qu’il
faudrait, notre anomalie est positive et représentée
en rouge. A l’inverse, si c’est inférieur,
pif anomalie négative, paf du bleu.
Mais vous allez me dire c’est pas le rayon
de la Terre qui varie comme ça là. Alors
non effectivement, le rayon est un des éléments
qui va influencer la pesanteur mais pas que
! Ca dépend aussi de plein de choses, notamment
l’altitude et, très intéressant, la densité
des roches sous nos pieds. Si on est assis
sur un kilomètre de sel, c’est léger,
d’abord on aura les fesses irritées, et
ensuite la gravité sera plus faible que si
on était assis sur une bonne grosse couche
de granite. Et voilà pourquoi les Bretons
sont lourds.
Donc ici, on a corrigé tous les autres effets
sur la pesanteur (le rayon de la Terre, l’altitude,
tout ça) pour que ça ne dépende plus que
de la densité des roches du sous-sol. En
rouge, ce sont les endroits où les roches
sont plus denses (donc là où la pesanteur
est plus forte) que ce à quoi on s’attend
en théorie. En bleu, là où elles sont plus
légères.
Et voilà comment on utilise la géodésie
physique pour scanner le sous-sol !
Oui, je suis en train de vous dire qu’on
arrive à déterminer quel genre de cailloux
on a sous nos pieds, ou même s’il y a des
failles ou d’autres structures du genre
sans creuser, en étudiant le champ de pesanteur
terrestre. Et on peut même en faire des modèles
3D !
Et même des modèles dynamiques, qui évoluent
dans le temps, puisque oui, la pesanteur varie
en fonction du lieu mais aussi dans le temps
! Ca dépend notamment des marées, (le Soleil
comme la Lune vont exercer une attraction
gravitationnelle sur la Terre qui va se déformer
un peu à leur passage et ça va réduire
le champ de gravité terrestre), mais ça
dépend aussi de la fonte des glaciers, la
tectonique des plaques, toussa. On voit bien
les dorsales océaniques sur cette carte,
d’ailleurs.
Donc vous imaginez bien que la gravimétrie,
ça peut servir dans plein de domaines ! On
peut s’en servir pour voir ce qu’il y
a sous les océans ou les déserts, pour surveiller
les volcans actifs, les nappes phréatiques,
les glaciers, les calottes polaires, étudier
les dômes de sel, détecter les cavités
souterraines, étudier la structure d’une
chaîne de montagne, certains gisements ou
même des sites archéologiques. C’est pas
mal utilisé aussi par les entreprises de
prospection qui cherchent des ressources dans
le sous-sol pour savoir où creuser. Ben oui,
ils vont pas juste creuser des trous au petit
bonheur la chance jusqu’à ce que le pétrole
jaillisse. Ca marche pas comme ça.
Et là vous vous dites wow mais comment font-ils
pour mesurer la gravité ? Ca doit être des
machines super high tech, et ben non, c’est
avec des bidules qui pendouillent au bout
d’un ressort ! Bon c’est des super bidules
de très haute précision (au 9e chiffre après
la virgule au moins), mais on n’est pas
loin de nos Guyanais avec leur horloge. Je
vous la fais courte, selon l’intensité
de la pesanteur, le bidule va plus ou moins
descendre, et on va pouvoir mesurer la longueur
du ressort. C’est le principe de base des
gravimètres. Après si on veut être un peu
tape à l’oeil on peut aussi dégainer des
gravimètres avec bobine supraconductrice,
mais bon.
Sinon y’a un autre moyen que je trouve particulièrement
élégant. On utilise des satellites. L’altitude
d’un satellite va être directement influencée
par la valeur de la pesanteur. S’il survole
une chaîne de montagnes un peu costaude,
il va être plus attiré par la Terre et donc
descendre légèrement. Suffit de suivre le
chemin tracé par ce chauffard spatial en
état d’ébriété pour savoir comment varie
le champ de pesanteur. Je vous avais dit que
c’était classe !
Pour la petite histoire, un de mes relecteurs
(Loïs si tu me regardes) m'a appris qu'il
y a dans le ciel deux satellites destinés
à ces mesures qui s'appellent Tom et Jerry
parce qu'ils se suivent en permanence.
Revenons-en enfin à cette belle patate qu’est
le géoïde. Oui, enfin on en parle ! Le géoïde,
c’est un concept qui remonte à 1873, quand
le mathématicien allemand Johann Benedict
Listing l’a sorti de son chapeau. On peut
le définir comme une surface équipotentielle
de référence du champ de pesanteur terrestre.
Vous n’avez rien compris, ça tombe bien,
moi non plus.
En gros, on a transformé la Terre en une
patate imaginaire. La particularité de cette
patate, c’est que c'est une surface qui
est horizontale partout. On dirait pas comme
ça. L'intensité de la gravité change, et
c’est ce qui explique les irrégularités
de cette patate, mais cette surface est partout
perpendiculaire à un fil à plomb.
Imaginez que vous voulez construire un plancher
bien horizontal partout. Vous vous munissez
d'un fil a plomb, qui vous donne la verticale.
Si la Terre était parfaite, à la fin on
devrait obtenir une sphére. Mais, n’en
déplaise à Parménide, quand on le fait
pour de vrai on obtient un patatoïde. Justement
parce que les masses rocheuses à l’intérieur
de la Terre n’ont pas la même densité
partout, et que les grumeaux les plus denses
vont dévier la direction du fil à plomb,
donc celle de la verticale.
Par convention, on a placé le géoïde au
niveau de la mer - le niveau moyen hein, sans
tenir compte des vagues, des courants ni des
marées. Donc le géoïde suit globalement
les océans et se prolonge sous les continents.
Mais à quoi bon cette patate ? M’interrogeâtes-vous.
Eh bien le géoïde sert de référence, notamment
pour les mesures de gravimétrie dont on a
parlé mais aussi pour tout ce qui peut avoir
à faire avec la pesanteur, par exemple pour
les calculs de trajectoire des fusées ou
des satellites.
Et les couleurs que vous voyez sur cette patate
que je vous montre depuis le début, c’est
les écarts du géoïde par rapport à la
forme idéale de la Terre, qu’on appelle
ellipsoïde de référence. Les deux ne s’écartent
pas plus d’une 100aine de mètres.[j][k]
En rouge, le géoïde fait une bosse là où
le sous-sol est soudainement plus dense, par
exemple sous une montagne. En bleu, il passe
au contraire en-dessous de l’ellipsoïde
de référence. Ca fait un creux.
Bon les reliefs sont évidemment très exagérés,
en vrai la Terre est quand même vachement
ellipsoïdale, on a assez d’images d’elle
de l’espace pour le confirmer.
Moralité, la Terre n’est pas plate. Ce
n’est pas non plus une colonne tronquée,
une sphère parfaite ni un kebab, c’est
un ellipsoïde de révolution. Mais si on
prend en compte son champ de pesanteur et
ses variations, alors c’est carrément une
grosse patate. Et la beauté de la chose,
c’est qu’on peut aussi faire de la géodésie
sur d’autres astres ! Ici, le géoïde de
la Lune, qui pour le coup est beaucoup plus
bosselé puisqu’il peut s’écarter de
plus de 700 m de l’ellipsoïde de référence
![l]
Et pour finir, je vous offre un petit cadeau
: voici à quoi ressemblerait la Terre si
elle arrêtait de tourner.
Normalement vous avez toutes les clés pour
comprendre pourquoi les océans se concentrent
vers les pôles et pourquoi on pourrait se
faire une petite rando de Nairobi à Kuala
Lumpur. Si vous voulez vous essayer à expliquer
ce qu’on observe, la section commentaires
vous attend !
4. Outro
Cette vidéo n’est pas sponsorisée par
le lobby des pommes de terre mais par…
Merci d’avoir suivi cette longue vidéo,
j’espère qu’elle vous aura appris quelques
trucs, spéciale dédi aux géographes. Un
spécial merci à tous ceux qui m’ont aidée
à défricher le sujet sur Touiche, cette
vidéo, c’est un peu la vôtre aussi. Et
moult mercis aux tipeurs qui soutiennent cette
chaîne et me permettent de vivre de ma passion,
faire des blagues nulles en prenant les cailloux
comme prétexte. Les cailloux mais pas que
d’ailleurs, vous avez peut-être vu que
la chaîne se diversifiait un peu dans ses
sujets, évidemment je continuerai à causer
de géologie. N’hésitez pas à me donner
votre avis, je ferai semblant que ça m’intéresse.
Et évidemment un immense merci aux relecteurs
qui m’ont empêchée de dire des bêtises
et m’ont proposé des supers analogies pour
expliquer des trucs pas toujours faciles à
comprendre, en fait c’est eux qui ont fait
tout le boulot.